ce soir c'est le grand retour du conseil
de paris s'était pas la grande forme o o
voilà à teaser
le pourquoi du comment on dirait c'est
pardon je vous explique le pourquoi du
comment au dîner il ya une explication
après les retrouvailles entre rachida
dati et anne hidalgo
grâce à nos invités
c'était jamais
[Applaudissements]
là ça va être dur là la charrette dur de
répéter
c'est pas grave j'étais tellement
heureux c'est dommage a menti ça partait
en superman ça finit en chaque fois
réalistes il un test au micro tue-t-il
des mouches est il le dernier soutient
d'hidalgo à l'applaudissent à moi qu'il
s'agisse du bruiteur officiel de roland
garros
si vous avez
cru
97% des célibataires sont sensibles aux
rires il est très important de montrer à
votre partenaire potentiel que vous êtes
drôle moi je trouve que ça marche pour
un garçon moi une fille drôle c'est pas
forcément soirée recherche voilà non
c'est pas la première chose non si c'est
si elle est drôle sous la dent c'est bon
c'est pas la première chose que vous
recherchez du coup j'ai une balle humour
un an après moi c'est là c'est la
gentillesse
j'essaie de faire une flûte de pan vals
fr je ramène à mon frérot musicos en
herbe il à être les instruments du monde
j'ai serré au genre de mec on te lâche
sur la banquise toujours appris qu en
costard cravate
go
[Applaudissements]
alors l'humour c'est à dire que tu
arriveras tahiti
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ils nous provoquent des [ __ ] notre
buzzer ils marchent pas et du deuil sont
complètement
je suis dégouté je me cale est en fait
la casse alors je suis mauvais joueurs
s'est pas c'est pas moi c'est
ça les endormis musique c'est les adore
ça les perses et amiens non un peu de
musique en secondes de brutt
et non mais alors bon
mais franchement alors lever le doigt
messieurs lévy a levé doit ce vraiment
qu'ils peuvent craquer juste en ont
maintenant quatre à gozée septembre
dernier la belle humour moi je dis que
ça ne marche pas une femme qui arrive
vers un homme et qui lui raconte une
blague de toto ou je sais pas quoi c'est
pas ça qui va par
là je veux c'est un peu lâché mais
alors l'étude a commencé par une
question très difficile quel membre de
votre famille aimez-vous moins que votre
animal de compagnie et on a interrogé
donc toutes ces personnes résultat ils
sont 81% à affirmer que leur animal de
compagnie conte de plus qu'au moins un
membre de la famille et les premières
victimes de ce constat sont les frères
et soeurs 57% m plus leur animal que
leur frère ou leur soeur alors julien
tomas qui voyez vous un chien j'ai un
lancinant alors je tiens l'illusion est
effectivement le pays de deir ezzor
quand même un robot ces robots un robot
chien en fait pas exactement un enfant
déguisé en chien mieux que ça c'est un
japonais figurez-vous dont le rêve était
de devenir un singe en
hiver ne suis pas connaissance de
l'excentricité des japonais 14000 euros
et va bien vous même il est raide
devenir animal est bien la vidéo fait le
buzz sur internet en deuxième position
la maman 50% on espère leur animal n'a
leur mère mais si un tiers alors adressé
faut
un tir explique que leur animal passe
avant leurs partenaires en gros je
préfère mon chien à ma femme enfin
oui
des emails professionnels au beau milieu
des vacances pour ne pas gâcher ces
moments précieux il existe des réponses
automatiques classique où l'option
médine island ou des chevaux écrivain
mot d'absence à votre place et puis en
fait question pour promouvoir ses
activités l'office du tourisme du pays a
fait les choses en grand construit un
clavier pour chevaux et dresser trois
spécimens à tapoter dessus avec de tels
messages le destinataire devrait
comprendre que vous n'êtes pas
disponible enfin 60 % préfèrent avoir un
animal compagnie plutôt de compagnies
plutôt que faire des enfants voilà dans
leur projet cqc cette citation célèbre y
en a qui font des enfants parce qu'ils
peuvent pas avoir de chien oui
je suis prêt des proches plus je connais
les hommes plus j'aime mon chien de
défense et être le meilleur résumé de ce
sondage